in 2015 this man Joshua Boyle wrote a
letter to his parents in Canada telling
them his wife Caitlin had just given
birth to a son he wrote that he
delivered the baby himself in the dark
holding a flashlight in his mouth this
was the second time that Caitlin had
given birth while the couple was being
held captive by the Taliban in the
remote mountains of Afghanistan near the
Pakistani border in late August of 2016
the families released a really startling
video videos have come out at different
points showing this couple what was
unique in this video is for the first
time
Caitlin Coleman explicitly said there
have been threats to her entire family
and by implication to her children
willing to kill us willing to kill women
to kill children so why would the
Taliban keep this family alive for so
long it doesn't fit with what we're used
to seeing on the news these barbaric
images of Western hostages killed in the
name of an ideology we often conflate
Taliban al Qaeda Islamic state and we
think that they're all kind of the same
and they're not the Taliban thinks they
can get something out of keeping this
family alive it's a mindset that sets
them apart from other militant groups
and it's key to understanding how they
operate Coleman Boyle and their children
are being held by a Taliban affiliate
group known as the Haqqani network the
Haqqani has got their start in the 1980s
like the Taliban they were part of the
rebel group known as the Mujahideen who
fought against the Soviet Union after it
invaded Afghanistan in 1979 the
Mujahideen was armed and financed by the
CIA you'll go back to it one day because
your fight will prevail and you'll have
your homes and your mosques back again
because your cause is right and God is
on your side
the Mujahideen drove out the Soviets in
1989
then came years of civil war with
Haqqani x' and other groups fighting to
gain power makani's allied themselves
with the Taliban when that group took
control of the capital Kabul in 1996 the
Taliban in the years before 9/11 were
government they had ministries they had
courts they had an army that all
disappeared after 9/11 when we invaded
bombed and basically broke the
government the Taliban had set up in
Afghanistan the Taliban wants to have
that government back they see themselves
at the rightful government of
Afghanistan they want to run Afghanistan
again since the us-led invasion the
Taliban and Haqqani have worked together
orchestrating kidnappings and bombings
all with the goal of retaking the
country in 2013 the Connie is negotiated
in exchange with the US for an American
service member named Bowe Bergdahl whom
they captured four years earlier private
first class Bowe Bergdahl was captured
after leaving his base in Afghanistan
for reasons that are still unclear the
US government considered Bergdahl a
prisoner of war rather than a hostage
and secured his freedom by exchanging
five Taliban prisoners who were held at
the US base in Guantanamo Bay Cuba and
with this latest video we get a glimpse
of what the Taliban and the Haqqani are
hoping to get out of holding Coleman and
her family I told that the Afghan
government is executed from among the
prisoners they have taken of these men
and that recently they hanged them and
our captors are terrified at the thought
of our own mortality approaching and
saying that they will take reprisals on
our family he's referencing six Taliban
prisoners who the Afghan government put
to death in May for their roles in a
suicide bombing and when he talks about
his captors being fearful for their own
mortality
he's likely talking about an AUSA Connie
the son of the group's founder an Afghan
judge sentenced him to death for helping
raise money for the Haqqani network and
it seems pretty clear what the Haqqani
is and the Taliban want to trade Coleman
Boyle and their family for a nossa
Connie but in order for that to happen
the US would have to do something it
says it
do no she ate with terrorists because
although the Afghan Taliban is not on
the US government's list of terrorist
organizations the Haqqani network is the
United States says again and again and
again we do not negotiate with
terrorists there will be no negotiation
with terrorists of any kind no nation
can negotiate with terrorists
we didn't negotiate with terrorists and
that's just empirically false the United
States talks to terror groups all the
time
groups like the Taliban are seen as very
rational groups groups like al-qaeda and
especially the Islamic state are seen
very very differently for Isis taking
hostages is about fear and propaganda if
they capture an American they wouldn't
necessarily want to trade them more
likely they'd want to kill them and
unfortunately they'd want to kill them
in as brutal a fashion as possible
but the Taliban and the Haqqani --zz
have very different goals from al Qaeda
and the Islamic state the Taliban and
the Haqqani --'s want to control
Afghanistan unlike Isis and al Qaeda
they have no interest in a worldwide
Islamic caliphate no interest in
attacking other countries no interest in
inspiring lone wolf attacks halfway
across the globe instead they're looking
to make a deal
you